One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. Where's your playlist taking you? Down the highway? To the mountains? next adventure. List is a great trip. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Book, direct, and save at bestwestern.com. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry. Yep, I did it. Jenna, okay, I don't even I'm so sorry. Um, yep. I did it. Jenna, okay, I don't even know where to start. Okay, first of all, for Christmas, Sam gave us each a sweatshirt. Like an ugly Christmas sweatshirt. Yeah, but they're all Keanu Reeves in some situation. Yeah. Like mine says Merry Wickmas. Thank you, Sam. Jenna Warhurst today, you guys, and I wasn't prepared for it to be right across from me this whole time. It
is Keanu is like maybe a patron saint. Yep. And he's holding a dog, a little dog, like he's rescued a dog, but he's like a saint. He has like the halo thing. How do you feel about looking into his sweet eyes? He's looking off. He's he's like a saint. He has like the halo thing. How do you feel about looking into his sweet eyes? He's looking off. He's not looking right at you. He's gazing that way, but he is right on your chest. Yeah, here's the thing. I love this sweatshirt. You walked through the streets in this. You got in your car. Oh, not just that. Oh, yeah. Well, you should tell them.
I had a morning. She told me, OK, she said, Ange, I'm going to wear kind of a fun outfit today. I'm going to surprise you. And we haven't shared with you, we're doing subtle sexuality today. And I thought, oh, I bet she's coming in a gold leotard. Oh, no.
No. This is what you think. You thought I was going to dress like subtle sexuality? Oh, I bet she's coming in gold leotard. Oh no, Mike, no! This is what you think, you thought I was gonna dress like subtle sexuality? Yes, because I considered doing it, but then I didn't. I did, but I didn't have time. And then I had an old leotard and I put it on and you know what, it hugged things in all the wrong spots. Well, I wanted to wear this because I love it and I don't care that it's Christmas themed. The holidays are over, but I didn't get to wear it in the holidays. So I'm going to wear it today.
I'm bringing that energy into the new year. But just say you thought you were just getting in your car and driving to the studio. And then we all got a text on the way here. Sorry to laugh, lady. But you said, oh no, I've got a flat tire. Yeah. I was about to get on the highway and I saw my tire gauge go red. It was almost flat. I had enough time to stop, fill it
with air and then drive it to the tire place. Where you met several folks that work at the tire place wearing this Keanu piece. I did. So let me tell you something. They got me fixed up in 20 minutes. And I think it's thanks to Keanu because when I walked up and I said, hey, I got my tire, I think is... Can I please take your picture so people know what you look like right now? He pointed at my sweatshirt and he laughed and he said, that is amazing. Oh, I love it.
And we were just, we hit it off from the beginning. So clearly Keanu, he was looking out for you today. My patron saint, Keanu. Yeah. They saw the sweatshirt. They're like, this lady needs help. Was an office fan as well. Oh, told him about our podcast, took a photo. I told him I throw it up in our stories since he was my hero of the day. Oh, amazing.
Well, listen, that wasn't gonna be my top of show share today. I actually have a fun one. If you don't mind taking another minute. I saw this meme lady. What? I saw meme. Remember memes? What are they again? It's not like a picture with words on them. OK, it's not a gif. No, it doesn't move.
And it says that what you should do to find out your fortune for the year 2025 is you should look up what movie was number one at the box office when you turned 10 years old. And that movie is like your fortune for the year. Gosh, when I was 10, I was in Indonesia. I have no idea what the movies were. I looked up all of our birthdays
and I can tell you everyone's fortune for the year. Really? Mm-hmm. All right, Angela, your movie is Superman 2. Oh. And in Superman 2, Superman gives up his powers to live a normal life with Lois Lane at the exact same time that three big villains
are let onto the planet. The ones dressed all in black? Yes, and they don't have their, he doesn't have his powers. They were like in a little triangle, but like an asteroid hit it or something, and they all came to Earth. They all came to Earth, you remember it.
So listen, Ange, I think the moral here is do not give up your superpowers this year to live a normal life. We need you. Done. Okay? Well, I'll keep my superpowers at party planning and scrapbooking and taking pictures of plants on my walk. We need this.
Wait, does Superman like to eat? Because I do have some superpowers in the kitchen and I wasn't sure where to share this, but I have a really big fun share. Yes, oh, you have to share this, Angela. Sharing is one of your superpowers. Do it! All right, well, this is an exclusive.
I'm sharing with you all first. Those of you guys that have been listening to the podcast and following us for all these years know that my husband, Josh, is an amazing baker and cook. And he and I have been working on a cookbook for the last year and a half. And guess what? I can finally tell you the name of it
and you can order it. Guess what the name is? You already know Jenna. I'm looking at you like guests, but you're like, I already know. It's called, You Can Make This. And I love this title because Josh came up with it. It's sort of a little inside joke with our family
because whenever me and the kids are trying to tackle a recipe, he makes it so simple for us and he'll look at us and say, you can make this. And these recipes are so special. Josh has really been thoughtful about picking them. They are our family favorites. And there's really something for everyone in the cookbook.
There's meals, side snacks, yummy desserts, and the recipes are simple, delicious, and guess what? You can make this. You can make this. I can make this, I've made this. You've made this. I make Josh's recipes all the time. I do his baking recipes, I do his one sheet meals. Oh my gosh, he's got soups. I know, he loves the time. I do his baking recipes, I do his one sheet meals.
Oh my gosh, he's got soups. I know, he is a great cook. Well, I'm so proud of it. And you know, we took the photo that's on the book cover in our home and I'll put a swipe up where you can pre-order cause that's a big deal. Yes.
The pre-sales are kind of what set the book apart to succeed. So if you guys go and pre-order, I would love you so much. And I promise you're gonna love the cookbook. I promise you're gonna love it too. All right, Ange, I loved that. And now, Sam, it's your turn. Yes.
Here's yours. Okay. D2, The Mighty Ducks. Oh, all right. Oh. Emilia Estevez? Yep. Yes. Yep. That's a good movie.
Yep, and here's what happens in that. You know, they're high on their wins, so they're kind of leaning into their fame. OK. And they have to get back into training so that they can take on Iceland. Oh. So I don't know what this is, Sam, but I think Iceland's
coming for you. OK, I'm going back to audio engineering school. Just, you know. To learn podcasts. Because someone in Iceland is coming for us. Okay, great, I look forward to meeting you. Okay, Cassie, your film is Liar Liar. Hey, that's a great one.
So I think this year you won't be able to tell a lie and this will lead to hilarious hijinks for you. You know what, let's do it. This is the year Cassie burns it to the ground. We're gonna have a segment called Get Real with Cassie. And mine is Footloose. Oh, that's a great one. Yeah, I actually, I turned it on this morning
and watched a little bit of it with my breakfast. You're gonna go against the system, lady? I don't know. Here's what I think. I'm going to have a year of political and social drama, lots of stressful situations coming at me constantly, all of which can be solved with a little dancing. You're going to dance through this year, lady. I'm dancing through.
Whatever comes your way, you're going to dance through it. It's not going to be easy, but I'm dancing through it. Yeah. And I'll say I loved having a little side of Kevin Bacon with my eggs this morning. Oh, honey. See what I did there?
You did a dad pun. You did it. I wore Keanu, but this Christmas, Sam, maybe it's Kevin Bacon? Maybe Kevin Bacon on a sweatshirt? I'll put the word out. Thank you. Okay.
All right, that's it. Well, that was a fun meme. Yeah, so everyone, you can find out what your fortune is for the year by finding out what movie was number one at the box office when you turned 10 years old. Have fun. Well, speaking of dancing,
we have a really fun episode this week. It is the web series, Subtle Sexuality, and the follow-up music video, Girl Next Door. Yes! This webisode starred Mindy Kaling, B.J. Novak, Ellie Kemper, Oscar Nunez, Ed Helms, and Brian Baumgartner. Here's a little summary for you. Kelly and Erin form a girl group called Subtle Sexuality and they produce their first music video for their song Male Prima Donna. The music video stars the two of them, Anne, Ryan, and Andy. Oscar is annoyed and Kevin is looking for a way to participate. And these are really fun. They are so fun. I wish they would have aired like regularly. Oh, I have a fan comment about that later. Okay. Well, we have a ton of great
behind the scenes stuff for this webisode series. I want to give a big thank you just right out of the gate to Joya Balfour, who was at NBC Digital at the time. She gave us so much scoop. I can't wait to sprinkle it throughout this episode. She really did. She really came through. So you guys remember when we shared about the accountants webisode, we talked about how incredibly popular these webisodes were.
I mean, groundbreaking, award-winning. Well, subtle sexuality continued the trend. Subtle sexuality ran on both NBC.com and Hulu. And Joya Balfour told us, to this day, Subtle Sexuality remains the most streamed web series of any scripted show on NBC. And it beat all but three of the network's full episodes during its first week online. It also became a number one music video on iTunes and the number four single. I know.
Listen to this, Joya sent us a screen grab she took when this single hit. It's the top 10 songs on iTunes in October of 2009 when the webisodes premiered. I just wanna read you where it landed. I want you to hear who all was in that top 10. Ready? Yeah.
The number one song was 15 by Taylor Swift. Number two, Thriller by Michael Jackson. That always resurfaces around October. Okay. Number three, Party in the USA by Miley Cyrus. Number four, Mel Primadonna by Subtle Sexuality. Number five was Meet Me Halfway by Black Eyed Peas. Number six, One Less Lonely Girl by Justin Bieber.
Number seven, Fireflies by Owl City. Number eight was Five Star by Yo Gotti. Number nine, You Belong to Me by Taylor Swift. Number 10, You Belong to Me by Taylor Swift. Mel Prim to me by Taylor Swift. Number 10, you belong to me by Taylor Swift. Mel Prima Donna beat Taylor Swift. Well Taylor Swift beat Mel Prima Donna, but then Mel Prima Donna beat Taylor Swift. But Mel Prima Donna also beat Justin Bieber. I mean, this is, can you believe it?
No, that's crazy. So you know, with the success of the Accountants webisodes, this time around NBC knew that they were going to get a huge audience so they went all out. When it premiered they had a home page takeover of NBC.com. The first thing that landed was Subtle Sexuality if you went to NBC.com. Wow. They also built a separate website for Subtle Sexuality and this webisode series was featured in Entertainment Weekly and in Us Weekly. And Joya sent us the Entertainment Weekly photo
with the little blurb. So I'll share that in stories. I'm gonna be sharing a ton in stories this week. And they also had a ton of fun with merchandise. They had custom CD designs, lyrics and liner notes, downloadable band posters, fan giveaways, t-shirts. They went all out. Well fans couldn't get enough of this Erin and Kelly storyline. They even had a follow-up song and music video Girl
Next Door. You can still watch all of this on Peacock and NBC.com. They have both. I also really liked Girl Next Door. It's really catchy. Mm-hmm. Yeah. I mean, we'll get to that later. Yes, we're going to break all of this down. And I wanted to share, you know, the first webisode series, The Accountants, was written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Schurr. It was directed by Randall Einhorn. Subtle Sexuality was directed by Mindy Kaling. And it was written by our writer's assistants,
Nate Fetterman and Jonathan Hughes. You guys might remember Nate Fetterman from Stress Relief. When we broke down that episode, he had the makeout scene with Cloris Leachman, and he shared his story with us. It's a great story. If you want to go back and listen to it, it's awesome. Well, we reached out to Nate again and he shared a bunch of stuff with us
that we'll be sprinkling in today as we discuss these webisodes. There is so much fun behind the scenes stuff about the making of this series as well. BJ Novak had this to say about Mindy being the director and I thought it perfectly sets up what we're about to talk about. BJ said,
She has such a distinct vision. She very much gravitates towards things that are fun and sparkly. And this is a very fun and sparkly webisode series. Oh, yes! Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, it'll be time for some subtle sexuality. I think Keanu has some subtle sexuality. You think?
This segment is brought to you by Macy's. Well it's the sweetest time of year. Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the, it's the sweetest time of year. Valentine's Day is approaching, and Macy's has the best of the best gifts for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. The perfect Valentine's Day looks different for everyone. Some people go all out.
Some people keep it simple. Lady, if we had to plan the perfect Valentine's Day for everyone on the office. The characters on the office. Yes. What would it be? I was trying to think about Jam and Valentine's Day. And you know, I did a whole breakdown on how they do not have a good track record for Valentine's
Day. Their Valentine's Day almost always stinks. So if I had to plan a good Valentine's Day, honestly, I think it would just be like, maybe they get to finally go have a nice dinner, maybe go to a Philly basketball game. I don't know. Maybe they could do like a brunch date and then go to some art museums. I guess it depends on who plans it. Exactly. I know what they don't want to do on Valentine's Day. They do not want to be in a throuple with Robert, California. No, they do not.
No. Well, the one person we know who is going to have a great Valentine's Day is always Phyllis because Bob Vance goes all out. And let me tell you, he would go to Macy's because they have everything, perfume, chocolates, jewelry, handbags. He'd probably get her some silk nightie. Yeah, something for the boudoir. Yeah, of anyone on the show, we know Phyllis is having a good Valentine's Day.
Yeah. Michael would probably want to be the center of attention. So he would like take his date to his improv show. Yes. That would be his gift to her. To make her watch him do improv. Yes. That was Cassie's idea.
I absolutely love that, Cassie. Well, Macy's really does fit so well into anyone's Valentine's Day plans. In fact, I have a pitch for people this Valentine's Day. If you haven't gotten them anything, you could make like a little coupon for like a shopping spree. Oh, that's fine. And then you just take them to Macy's and you can sit and watch them try stuff on or like smell the perfume or whatever it is but like a shopping spree date. Fashion show, fashion show, fashion show at lunch. Yes! You know we are huge supporters of Macy's all year long and they make shopping so simple for every occasion with their gift guides. We love their gift guides
and hand-picked gifts for everyone on your list. It takes all the guessing work out of the process. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in-store or online at macy's dot com slash gift guide. I was sick, but I am healing. Returning to W Network and StacTV. The West Side Ripper is back. If you're not killing these people, then who is? That's what I want to know. Starring Kaylee Cuoco and Chris Messina. The only investigating I'm doing these days is who shit their pants.
Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I got to get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on Stack TV. Ready to make your next big move? Rotman Executive Programs at the University of Toronto offers top tier professional development. Whether you're moving up in your current role or preparing for the next,
expand your business acumen, sharpen leadership skills, and gain cutting edge insights from world class Rotman faculty. Accelerate your career with Rotman executive programs. Visit www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025 to learn more. That's www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025. Hello, we are back and we're going to start breaking down this webisode. So Nate told us that when he and Jonathan were approached to write the next set of webisodes, Mindy pitched an idea that Kelly and Erin were creating a Twilight fan fiction movie. So Nate and Jonathan worked with her to develop that idea. They kind of landed on a structure where we would see the making of the movie.
And then the final webisode in the series would be Kelly and Erin's short film. Well, I guess the folks at NBCUniversal were worried about clearance issues. So, they had to go back to the drawing board. Nate and Jonathan brainstormed some other areas that had that same kind of structure. And they pitched the idea that Kelly that same kind of structure, and they pitched the idea that Kelly and Erin start a girl group and make their first music video. Well, Nate said Mindy loved this idea. Right?
Fun and sparkly. Mm-hmm. And so did the execs at NBC, and so they were given the green light to write it. Well, on the official Subtle Sexuality website, they have a fun little synopsis of who the group is, and I thought I would read it. It says, there's nothing subtle about Subtle Sexuality. They're a girl group that features two diva-licious divas, the beautiful and mysterious Kelly Kapoor and the pretty Erin Hannon.
These independent ladies can do it all, sing, dance, be fierce they're salacious, and work it all at the same time. Straight out of Scranton, PA, their new single is inspired by Beyonce, Katy Perry, Jay Hud, and all the Kardashians. Tear it open and you'll never be able to put it back in the box because subtle sexuality is more than just a pop group, it's a way of life. Hmm, I do want to tell you all that on the website, Kelly's name is the biggest, everyone else's is kind of small.
Like the font? Yes. It's huge. And then it says at the bottom, featuring Nardog and Mr. Understood. Oh, these are their pop names. Mm-hmm. Got it. All right.
Well, we start with part one. It's titled Creative Differences. We find out that most of the office is away at a software training program. Mm-hmm. I guess this is how they explained why we're not all in the background. Right, and also why maybe they're shooting
at Dunder Mifflin, because no one's there, except for Oscar and Kevin. Yeah, they didn't need to learn the new software. They sent you, Angela, to represent. Accounting, clearly. Well, this is when we're going to find out that Kelly and Erin have decided to film their music video. We find out that the name of their band is Subtle Sexuality.
We go into the kitchen, and we see a shot of Kelly doing Ryan's makeup for the shoot. It's one of those classic moments where you only see Kelly and Ryan. Ryan's wearing a robe, and Kelly's putting on his eyeliner, and she's looking to camera and she's like, you know when you love a guy and he's giving you mixed signals but you know he really likes you and you're sleeping with him? And Ryan goes goes more eyeliner. And then Kelly goes I'll never tell you who the song is about this is a secret that I will take to my grave and Ryan goes it's about me and Kelly goes it is but I'll never say and then we reveal
Oscar has been sitting there the whole time just trying to eat a sandwich and he says do you guys need to do this here this This is a public area. And Kelly's like, it's our office too, Oscar. And then lady, I just love this. She says to Ryan, I think it's too much rouge. And he goes, no, it's not going to read on camera. And she's like, how do you know what's going to read on camera? And he goes, I lived in New York for 11 months.
Living in New York for 11 months tells you everything. I guess about what reads on camera. Cracked me up. Then Ryan has a super douchey talking head. Oh yeah. He's explaining why he's participating in the music video and he's like, what can I say? I love music.
And then he goes on to say, in fact, if he had to choose a life without sex or a life without music, he to choose a life without sex or a life without music he would choose a life without sex. I don't believe him. Well he says girls will find other ways to take care of me. I still don't believe him. All right now we're going to move to the parking lot and we're setting up our first shot of the music video. Yeah Kelly is dressed as a bride but she also was like smoking a cigarette like she's a tough girl. This whole look reminded me very much of early Madonna, like, like a virgin, that wedding
dress look. Yep. Erin is dressed as a minister and she's also working the camera. Yes. Ryan comes out, he's very impatient. He's like, my blood sugar is low. When are we getting to me? Kelly is trying to light a cigarette, and she yells at him and goes, you should have finished the soy yogurt I gave you. The level of stress while they're filming was cracking me up.
I also want to point out that Kelly has a splint on her finger. It's on her left pointer finger. This will pay off later. Yes. Also, lady, when I was watching Mindy try to smoke this cigarette in this scene, it was making me laugh. Did you ever have to smoke for a role? Did you ever have to smoke a cigarette for any of your characters? No, I have not. And I am telling you right now, I would just completely botch it. I don't know that I wouldn't quite know how to hold it or light it. I've never smoked.
So I wouldn't know what to do with it. I had to smoke in a movie. I had to smoke a lot in this movie called A Little Help. And I loved it was just a great part. It's a really great movie. And I was so afraid that I was gonna look like a nonsmoker, which is what I am for all the things you're saying. I mean, I'm sure a real smoker,
they can probably tell right away. Yeah, well, I mean, I started smoking as soon as I got the part. I just started slowly smoking. Like what? Like those? I couldn't do the fakies. I couldn't do the fakie clove cigarettes so that I had I had like a four month period of my life where I smoked cigarettes. That's insane, lady. I know insane. Yeah.
Was it gross? Do you want the truth? Or do you want me to say what I should say? Cassie, Cassie, this is your year. I think I know what you wanna say. There was a lot about it that I liked. Okay, well, you must- Don't smoke everybody.
There was a lot about it that messed with my sinuses. And I was like, by the end of the four months, I was like, this is, I can't do this and I have to quit. And I did. And I'm glad I did. But you smoked for the movie. And I smoked not just on camera. I mean, I had to smoke in my life. I would, you know, practice smoking while I drove my car because I had a scene where I had to smoke in my life. I would, you know, practice smoking while I drove my car because I had a scene where I had to smoke in the car, and then I had a scene where I was walking down the street
talking to someone, so I would practice that. I had to practice lighting cigarettes because I wanted to get all the business correct. This is very good actor-Method-y stuff you did. Yeah. Yeah. But, you know, I really enjoyed having a cup of coffee and a piece of chocolate cake and a cigarette. I'm not, I mean, I'm so sorry. It sounds so, I don't know, it sounds so gross to me.
It was so good. And I mean, I feel so bad saying this, children don't smoke. But yeah, it was something about it. And it was, you know, it was relaxing all the things why people get addicted to it. I get it. Right, right. I get it. But I stopped because it also would make me wake up and I would blow my nose and it would be like brown and then I would have a sore throat and I would cough. I mean it had a horrible, in a short period of time, had horrible effects on my health. Well, I think this is a horrible transition, but Kelly did not do any of that research.
She's doing a horrible job lighting her cigarette, and then she starts coughing and choking, and then she says, excuse me, I think I have to go vomit. That's how this webisode ends. The next webisode in this series is called The Replacement. Mmm. Yeah. Who's getting replaced?
Erin has a talking head. She says, you know what? The shoot was going really well until Kelly and Ryan got in a fight. Then the poop hit the fan. Yeah. Erin is trying to calm Kelly down when Kevin approaches, and he says, you know what? Do you need someone to step in for Ryan? Cause I'll step in, I'll do it.
And Kelly clearly does not want him to step in for Ryan. So she makes him the cameraman and he's really happy about that. He's excited. Except he has jelly on his hands and they're like, you got to wipe that jelly off your hands before you hold the camera. So Kevin just wipes it on the file cabinet. So gross. Way to go, Kevin.
Kelly still has a splint on her finger here, still on her left hand, still on her pointer finger. While this conversation is going on, Andy is singing by the vending machines. He is singing to the tune of Beethoven's Fifth Symphony. Vending machine, vending machine, I want to treat something to eat. It's really funny. And of course, they overhear him singing and they're like, huh, this cuts to an
Andy talking head. And I absolutely loved it. He describes how he auditions for them. And I think you need to hear it. So they asked me to audition for subtle sexuality. So I gave them a little And I think you need to hear it. So they asked me to audition for subtle sexuality. So I gave them a little doodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodled I'm like, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, I was in a band and we used to mess with each other on stage like this all the time. And one of my friends who I was performing with that night was like, well, of course, she's an amazing beatboxer. And then the whole crowd looks at you and you're like, damn you.
So I think I did something like this. Pretty good, it's better than me. I don't know, I just made it up on the spot you guys, it's not good. That was good. Cassie, can you beatbox? Okay. It's a really cool thing that people can do. I actually find it really fascinating. No, I agree and I was wondering if Ed like just already kind of had that skill or if he read the script
and was like, oh boy, kind of like you with the improv. Because that happens. Like sometimes they'll write something for you to do and you're like, wait, what? Wait, wait, what? Here we go. Well, Kelly is now going over the choreography with Andy and Erin for the video. She says one and two and cross and cross down, sexy, sexy, sexy. There is behind the scenes footage of this,
of them practicing the dances, and Mindy and Ellie talking about who's good at what dance move. It's so cute, this behind the scenes footage. I wanna include part of it in our stories. Well, I remember when they were getting ready to shoot this, that they were singing the songs on set between scenes. They were actually working on this stuff.
It was really fun. We were like, what are you guys doing? What are you guys doing? And then Ellie said in an interview that she was like listening to it, like at the gym, like on her run, like just learning the song. Yeah, cause they had to like lip sync it.
Yeah. Well, listen, Ryan is going to interrupt and he's finding out that he's being replaced. He is not happy about it. He's like, this guy, you're replacing me with this guy? And he's like, you know what, we've met before. And then Kelly has a line. It really cracks me up.
She goes, this video is bigger than you or me. Yeah. Doesn't stop Ryan though. He's going to grab her in an embrace. They're going to make out. And then Ryan says to her, I'll see you at five and Kelly kind of wistfully watches him leave and Andy's like, but can I still be in the video? All right, so now it is time. Part three of this web series is the music video. It is the music video
for Subtle Sexuality's song, Male Prima Donna. So good. Eve Nelson wrote the music for this song. She was our go-to music person. She is an Emmy award winning composer. She also wrote the original music for the song in Scott's Tots and all of the music for Threat Level Midnight. The song is just so catchy.
Vulture interviewed Mindy and they described the video like this. They channeled the look, sound and aesthetic of Lady Gaga's 2008 Just Dance and Kesha's 2010 song TikTok. I went back and watched both of those music videos. And did you see the influence? Yes, absolutely. We're not going to play the full song for you guys, but you've got to hear the chorus of Male Primad donna here it is Prima Donna. Prima Donna. Oh!
Lady, I had this song stuck in my head for days. Days. I mean, I'm going to sing it probably today. In the behind the scenes footage, there is a part where Ellie's in front of a microphone and Mindy's watching her and she's just going, oh! Oh! Oh!
Is that from when they were recording the song? Yes. And you can see Eve there, too. Listen, not only is this song amazing, I can't get enough of the costumes in this music video. They're very interesting and also very random. Very random. Also in the behind the scenes video,
you see them in the costume department, and they're clearly trying on different looks. I had to do a costume breakdown. I expected it. Okay. Well, their first look, I'm gonna start with Kelly. She's wearing gold spandex leggings with a sort of like a cheetah print leotard
and a big black chunky belt with long dark purple gloves up to her elbows and tall black boots. This is what you thought I was gonna wear in today. I thought you might wear gold. A version of this. I thought you might wear gold leggings or something. You said, look, I have an outfit.
Have you ever met me before? Lady. Gold leggings. Honey, not only have I met you and been your friend for years, but let's just talk about what you wore to Halloween that year, where you dressed like someone from the 1980s. I know I wore a neon track suit because I don't want anything you know tight.
Well you might wear some kind of gold lame I thought I thought you might wear something inspired. Cheetah print. Fair enough fair enough. Okay I'm not done with Kelly's first look. No go. She also has sort of like a blue lightning bolt thing on her cheek. This is very Lady Gaga in her Just Dance video. Okay. Okay. Erin is wearing the same gold spandex leggings and it looks like she has a black leotard
but then over the black leotard they put this gold sparkly tank top blouse with also a big black chunky belt. She has black gloves but they only go just a little bit past her wrist. And she also has the tall black boots. Then they have a second look, which we already talked about. It's Kelly as the bride and Erin as a priest.
Then they have a third look. I guess we're calling it sexy pirate. Yes, this was where they went in a new direction. Mm-hmm. They're dressed as like, yeah. Yeah. Sexy pirates. Yeah, yeah. That's what we're calling it. Kelly has a bedazzled silver and diamond patch over one eye. She has a silver sparkly knit hat. Erin has a full stuffed parrot on her shoulder with a black beret and then they both have these versions of like kind of a black and white outfit look, like with black and white stripes.
That's their third book. But then there's also a few shots of them as they're lip syncing and dancing to this song where they're just in their work clothes as well. Yeah, it like kind of cuts back to their normal day wear. Mm-hmm. There is a portion of the music video that finally explains the splint on Kelly's finger. Erin has a lyric that explains it. I thought we should listen.
You slammed her finger in the car door. Didn't say you're sorry. Love is long. She got stitches. It really hurt. That's her blood on your polo shirt. Yeah. She got stitches. It really hurt. That's her blood on your polo shirt. Yeah. She got stitches, it really hurt.
I love it. What's interesting is that at one point there's a shot of Kelly and the splint is on her ring finger. No, not her pointer finger. It traveled. Yeah, not sure which finger was injured. Well now Andy is gonna come in
and he's got a whole interesting look as well. Oh yes, I did a breakdown of Andy's outfit. Okay. Andy, clearly in the story of making this video, didn't have a lot of time to put a costume together. So what he's done is he's kind of transformed his work outfit into a costume. So he's wearing his t-shirt and he's wearing his same suit jacket, but he's ripped the arms off and then he's wearing his tie and he's tied his long sleeve shirt around his waist. Yeah, his button down is now like around his waist.
Yeah, so it's kind of flowing. He has also just cut off the bottom of his pants. Why? So it's a it's an interesting look. Andy's portion of the song is pretty fabulous. I thought maybe we should hear it. Oh yeah. girl, while when you flash that sexy smile because before she met you things were going okay
so go away or stay at the end there andy's harmonizing with himself yeah and they do this special effect where there's like three andys in one shot yeah he's like on either side of himself like bookends and then he's got also a pose in the middle. It's pretty special. It's great. So now Ryan comes in and his outfit is pretty incredible. Angela, do you have a breakdown of this one? Oh I do. So Ryan, first of all, you know his character is Mr. Understood. Yeah. He is wearing a white top hat, a white suit, with a pink handkerchief in his lapel pocket,
with black and white checkered socks, with white dress shoes, a long gold necklace with some type of gold medallion, and a gold flashy watch. But in the behind the scenes bonus footage, BJ and Mindy talk about his costume. And here's what they said. Kelly gets to kind of erupt in this webisode series but also Mindy Kaling
does too. She's directing these. She's in charge of my hair, she's in charge of my makeup, she's in charge of my wardrobe. It's sort of like Adam Levine meets boys to men type of thing. But he's gonna be wearing white shoes. I want her to wear a top hat and a cane. So she's handling the power very well. So she's handling the power very well. Cracked me up. You know what I love about this is that Mindy had a real vision. I mean, you can hear the detail in and the research that she put into this look and this music video and how it was gonna look. I mean, it's really phenomenal. It's really well directed.
Yeah. Well, I also thought we needed to hear Ryan's rap because it's so great. Yeah. So here is Mr. Understood. Call me Mr. Understood, cause no one understands me. But when I spit rhymes rhymes everybody buys my CD
You get out of the car so slow. How was I supposed to know you keep saying stuff behind my back? How come I got the number one track? I'm the OG prima donna my rhymes bite like piranha Hotter than a sauna straight out of Lackawanna Yeah, Lackawanna. Yeah. Lackawanna. Also, BJ's face as Ryan, or Mr. Understood, whatever we're calling him, when he goes piranha, he's so into it.
It's really pretty fabulous. The whole thing is pretty fabulous. And that's it. That's the end of this webisode, Subtle Sexuality. We're gonna take a break, but when we come back, we are gonna talk about Subtle Sexuality's follow-up music video, The Girl Next Door, and their making of documentary.
Which was narrated by Kevin Malone. Yes. ["The Girl Next Door"] Kevin Malone. Yes. Hello, dearest listener. In the thick of the winter season, you may be in need of some joie de vivre. Well look no further, honey, because Sunwing's Best Value Vacays has your budget-friendly escapes all the way to five-star luxury.
Yes, you heard correctly, budget and luxury all in one place. So instead of ice scraping and teeth chattering, choose coconut sipping and pole splashing. Oh, and book by February 16th with your local travel advisor or as. TD Direct Investing offers live support. So whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count. And whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count.
And if you're like me and think a TFSA stands for Total Fund Savings Adventure, maybe reach out to TD Direct Investing. Okay, we are back. Like we said before, this webisode series was so popular they produced two supplemental assets, if you will. Yes, the first supplemental video they released was a making of like a faux documentary of the band called Part-Time Band Full-Time Legend.
It's the story of subtle sexuality as told by Kevin Malone. It's a very dramatic introduction. I thought we could hear it. This, my friends, is the powerful story of subtle sexuality. Part-time band, full-time legend. Remember 2009? Music was headed in a wild new direction back then. Nobody thought the boundaries could be pushed any further. Yeah, pushed any further. There's a chiron on the screen that says Kevin Malone, Scranton music critic. Yes, there's going to be a series of talking heads and everyone will have a title. Yes. Kelly's talking head, she's titled as lead singer. And she's going to explain, they were just kids, you know, they didn't care what they were singing. They just wanted to be original. Erin also has a talking head. Her title is other band member.
And she says the best part was when they sang. Yeah. And then Andy has his talking head. His title is The Nard Dog. He's going over like, what does he love about subtle sexuality? And he just sort of says it's like an opportunity for him to express his musicianship and his sexuality all at once. Yeah. Yeah. He says he's cursed with overt sexuality. Yeah. I do want to point out during all of these interviews the setting is hilarious. Yes. Like Mindy thought of everything. So they are sitting in this room. There are candles on these tall pedestals and then the backdrop behind them is all this vibrant colors.
It looks like a bunch of like fans that you flip open, you know? But the colors are like purple and maroons. It kind of reminded me of like the talking heads that you see during like a bachelor or bachelorette show. Exactly. Like a reality show. Where they go to talk about if they got the rose or not and they're surrounded by candles and some backdrop. Yeah. Mindy thought of everything. So the next part of this documentary is gonna reveal, it's showing us their popularity. And so Kelly and Erin are in the conference room.
They've got a table full of merch. There's a line out the door of people who want their autograph. Yeah. Lady, did you see who was first in line? Tom Melby. Tom Melby. Tom Melby. I know.
We loved him. He was like our, what would you call him? He was like our everything man. He was like our handyman. Our superintendent, if you will, of the property. And his house was right behind our studio. Yeah. He was the person who would go in and water the plants
when we were all on vacation. I know. I ran into him recently. We were out at a farmer's market, and he was there. He was sitting, and he was having a margarita. Really? Yeah. And I said, Tom Melby?
And he couldn't believe it. And we got to chatting. He was so sweet. He just said how much he loved our book. and he just is a dear, dear person. Yeah, he is the kindest. I know I've talked about it before, but he would always let me take Isabel to his backyard, had a swing when she would come visit.
He's the sweetest. I just love that he's in this webisode. Me too. So listen, this table is full of merch. There's CDs, and people are wearing subtle sexuality t-shirts. I was like, oh my gosh, where is all this? I wish I had a subtle sexuality t-shirt. Well, lady, I reached out to Joya about this.
She has all of the original subtle sexuality artwork. And last night, guess what I did? What? What did you do? What are you doing? Why are you taking off your sweatshirt? No, you didn't. No, you didn't. All right. Everybody gets a subtle sexuality t-shirt. I printed them. We used an ironing board. Josh helped me. We made everyone shirts. And Sam, I know you love collecting pop culture stuff. So you get a shirt and a pillowcase.
Ooh, thank you. This is nuts. Oh my gosh. I love it so much. And they're different. You put different images. Yes, I had several images Joya gave me. And I can share these in our stories.
It's so cool. I have Mindy as the pirate. This is nuts. This is why I have been wearing this big bulky sweatshirt because I had to cover the t-shirt. I have been sweating my butt off over here. I was so happy to finally take it off. Lady, I am going to say it right now.
This is your superpower. What you just did with these t-shirts and bringing it in for everyone, you're always bringing in gifts. This is do not let this go to live a normal life this year. Okay. Okay. Keep this going in this year. My party planning committee spirit going.
Yes. I had to when I saw all of this artwork. I was like, this is so amazing. They really, really went for it. They really did. I just think they're fantastic. All right, so listen, now we're gonna have a series of talking heads where everyone is kind of reflecting on the popularity of their male prima donna hit.
Yes. They're so funny. My favorite is Ryan's. I have to play it. Okay. There was a time where. I have to play it. OK. There was a time where everywhere I went in Scranton, I would hear, Mel Primadonna. I'd go to my mom's house and I'd hear Mel Primadonna.
I'd go to my dad's house and I'd hear Mel Primadonna. I'd go to Kelly's sister's house party. They would randomly be playing Mel Primadonna. Everywhere he went. Everywhere. My mom's house. Yeah, Mel Primadonna. Male Primadonna.
His delivery of it is so funny. I know. It's just so good. So good. Well, we're going to find out that things went south pretty quickly for this group. I guess there was a performance they thought was going to be at a record label turned out to be a record store. Yeah.
Security actually made them leave. Yeah, but that's not the only drama that befell the singers of male prima donna Angela. We now learn that they've kicked Andy out of the band. Yeah. Which Andy doesn't seem to know. Yeah. This is gonna be a surprise to him. Yeah Ryan says you know he doesn't know what it is but Andy didn't have it. Mm have it. So they got rid of him. And now Kelly and Erin are going to announce that, you know what? Despite all of this drama, they're moving forward with their new song, The Girl Next Door.
Yeah. Well, you know, Kelly, Erin, and Ryan kind of explain what The Girl Next Door is going to be. And you can also hear the fact that Andy is surprised that they've already been working on it. Let's hear it. The Girl Next Door is our new song that we're recording. And in the video, Kelly is the star.
She is the girl next door. Yeah. I'm really excited. This is going to be a great video. She was also supposed to play the part of the Pretty Popular Girl, but Ryan doesn't have the technology to edit it that way. So they already shot it? I agree. It's weird for me to just play the everyday girl next door.
But I'm a good actress. I play the jock that Kelly and Erin are both obsessed with. I actually studied with a private acting coach for three months to nail the role. I'm just playing. Clearly I didn for three months to nail the role. I'm just playing. Clearly I didn't have to reach all that far. I think we just recorded our next number one. AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH So that ends this making of documentary.
And next they released the song and music video, The Girl Next Door. Yes. It also had a huge marketing push from NBC. It had a Facebook page, which Joya told us she is still the admin for. She's like, I don't think NBC realizes that. She also sent me screen grabs of all of this stuff, of the Facebook pages,
of comments that people left. I'm going to share it in our stories. The Girl Next Door website had pictures of Kelly, Erin, and Ryan. It also had dropdown tabs that said lyrics and credits, picks, free stuff, buy, fan club, and past projects. And it listed some thank yous. And I thought we could read them, Jenna. They're so funny.
Here's who Kelly would like to thank. Myself, for believing in me. Ryan Howard for the push all of the criticisms you gave me. Beyonce for being such a great role model. My sisters Ruka, Nipa, and Tiffany for nothing. Oh a little shade of the sisters. Yep. The VMA committee for selecting me as best new artist next year. And my stripper aerobics DVD for teaching me how to dance and look awesome. Amazing. And Erin had her own thank you section. Here is who she wanted to thank. Kelly Kapoor for letting me express myself through the song you wrote. Ellen DeGeneres for teaching me how to dance.
Ryan Howard for being so nice. Andy Bernard for being so nice. Michael Scott for hiring me and giving me the best job in the world. That nice man that called the ambulance after I fell out of the tree. Thanks, whoever you are. Those were her thank yous. The website page also includes the following credits for the song. It says lyrics by Nate Federman and Jonathan Hughes. And the music was, once again, by Eve Nelson and also Raymond Servenka, published by Barter Music, Inc.
and Exhibition Music, Inc. Yes, this music video was also directed by Mindy Kaling, and it was written by Kelly Hannon, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall. I should have said before that that making of video, that was written by Kelly Hannon and Jonathan Hughes as well. And directed by Mindy. I think so.
I couldn't find a credit for it, but I'm assuming directed by Mindy. Well, here is how the Girl Next Door video starts. Kelly is dressed in a pink zip-up hoodie with pink checkered fingernail polish. She's wearing glasses and her hair in sort of these long, low pigtails. They're in the kitchen break room at Dunder Mifflin. And she is playing checkers with Ryan, who is dressed in a letterman jacket. He's kind of got that jock look going. The opening credits say subtle sexuality featuring Rye Howard and then in quotations girl next door. The video
starts with a couplet of dialogue. Jenna, I think we should read it. You be Rye and I'll be Kelly. Okay, all right. This is me as Rye. So are you coming to my basketball game tonight? It's the state finals. Oh I don't think there's a bus stop by the sports dome. I don't know how I get there. Why don't I just pick you up? Oh okay. But wait everybody now Erin going to enter in a very sexy strapless party dress and she just kind of like struts past the table. Yeah. And, you know, Ry does a big double take at Erin and he gets up and he doesn't even look
over her shoulder at Kelly. He just says bye and he goes after Erin. And then that's when the music video starts. The lyrics are so great. I think we need to hear the beginning. Let's do it. high self-esteem. People say that I could be a vaginal queen. We could be just like Juliet and Romeo, Cleopatra and Marc Anthony, or Marc Anthony and J-Lo. I'm just the girl next door, and she's totally bored. I wish I could be more
I'm just the girl next door So catchy! Very catchy again. Yeah. In an interview with Vulture magazine, Mindy said it's a pop country song. She said there was elements of Carrie Underwood and Taylor Swift. And the video is based specifically on Taylor Swift's 2009 hit, You Belong with Me, in which Swift plays, as Mindy put it, both the girl next door and the hot bitchy girl. It's really amazing.
I mean, the whole music video is just like Mindy sort of pining away for the popular guy who's completely obsessed with Erin. She's like rides a bicycle with the basket in the front. I love Mindy's look with this, the pigtails and the glasses and she's wearing this pink hoodie, but sometimes a yellow hoodie. She looks completely adorable.
She looks so adorable. They do have a few outfit changes, but they're all in the same genre of their character. So Mindy has a few different hoodie looks, and Erin is in a few different types of cocktail dresses. And then Ryan has a few different letterman jackets. Yeah. My personal favorite shots are when
Mindy is singing behind the window, and it's like the rain is dripping down. But if you look beyond just the pane of glass that she's singing in front of, there's like no evidence of rain. It's like sunny in the parking lot and even the windows next to her. It's amazing. Let's not forget Ryan's other costume look is when he's dressed as an old man because guess what?
He realizes he should have picked the girl next door. But it's too late. It's too late because guess what? She died of a broken heart. Yeah. He goes to her grave site. He leaves her a checker from the checkerboard. Yeah, from the checkerboard.
He remembers playing checkers with her. All I could think about was like all of the different prop items Phil Shea had to make. I know. He had to make a tombstone. He did. Did you notice there is this one part where Aaron is like making out with Ryan in front of Kelly's desk? And I don't know if you could tell, but I think it's really obvious that they are not actually kissing. They're not even touching. They're doing that real fakey kind of like
hands moving but their faces aren't touching. I have this whole backstory that it was because like Kelly didn't want Aaron and Ryan to really kiss in this music video. Oh absolutely not. It's very funny. Well Subtle Sexuality had a whole world tour lined up according to their website. No. Yeah. It started October 29th and went until November 8th. That's also when the webisodes were released.
And they were mostly going to sing at karaoke bars and open mic nights. But around the world? No. Okay. Nope. But they were going to be the opening act at two events. Oh. On November 6, you could have found them headlining
at Aaron's apartment. Oh. OK. And on November 7, they were in Ithaca, New York at Statler Hall opening for the Cayuga Waiters, which, by the way, Statler Hall is on Cornell University's campus. And the Cayuga Waiters were the campus' oldest all-mil acapella which, by the way, Statler Hall is on Cornell University's campus, and the Cayuga Waiters were the campus's oldest all-male acapella ensemble. They were
dismissed as a group in 2017 as an outcome of an investigation into hazing. Oh, that took a turn I wasn't expecting. Sorry, but I think at the time this was written they were... They had not been dismissed yet, is what you're saying. Exactly. Right, we were not promoting a group that hazes into their own dismissal. That's right. Got it.
That was very liar liar of you, Angela. That was sort of keeping with Cassie's theme of the year. That was utter truth. Well, I just, of course, when I saw that they were gonna play at Statler Hall, I had to find out if it was a real place. Then I found out it was on Cornell. Then I found out that Cayuga Waiters
were an actual real acapella group. But then I- Until, until 2017. There was a little bit of a mom detective. It was, it sure was. I think it's a real kick in the nuts. I don't know, for Andy, that one of their tour stops was at his alma mater and he's not even in the band anymore. I have a feeling Andy... The poor guy.
Yeah. I have a feeling Andy set it up. Oh, and now he doesn't even get to go. I know, because they kicked him out of the group. Wow. Lady, all of this music video stuff, it got me thinking, I was in a music video, and you were in a music video. I know, isn't that crazy? Being in music videos is super fun. Yeah. I was in a music video for the old 97s.
It was for their song, Good With God. It was actually directed by Lee. What'd you do in it? Well, I had this fun little moment at the top. We did one of these things, like they did with Girl Next Door, where there's like a scene that leads into the music video. Yeah. And it was starring me and Fred Armisen and the band.
Oh, wow. And so the premise was that I was going to be like interviewing the band for my music show called An Hour and 60 Minutes. And Fred was going to be like the stagehand who kept interrupting our interview and like doing comedy bit and distracting us from the interview.
But here's the crazy thing that happened. When we showed up to film the video, the band, Old 97 said, we're so sorry, but our drummer, Philip Peoples, hurt his back. He couldn't fly in. He can't do the music video. Did Fred play the drums? Yes.
Because I know he plays drums. He's a drummer. He's really good. So we were like, how about we have Fred sit in as the drummer while you guys film this music video? So he did. So Fred is drumming in this music video for real. And then so for the top bit, we were like,
how about the bit is that we ask Fred to sit in as the drummer and we say you don't have to say anything during the interview, but then Fred keeps answering the questions as if he's a band member and he sort of takes over the interview. It was really funny. It was so fun. What a great pivot. It was a lot of fun. But Fred is a good friend of ours. He was in Lee's movie Ordinary World. We know him.
Yeah. He's awesome. He could make me laugh reading the phone ours. He was in Lee's movie Ordinary World. We know him. Yeah. He's awesome. He could make me laugh reading the phone book. He's so funny. So funny. And of course, Rhett and the band are amazing. The old 97s. I mean, I love them.
They're great. Well, mine wasn't as exciting as that. I was just like part of a crowd scene, you know? I've talked about this before. It was for Clay Walker's single, he's a country music artist, really nice guy. And there was a group of people that would sit around the stage, you know, as he played, but we're like out like, I feel like they were like bales of hay. It was supposed to look like country, like we're outside. Yeah. And it was filmed in New Mexico.
And I wore those. Remember when those- It was filmed in New Mexico. Did you get the job in LA and they traveled you to New Mexico? Oh no, I wasn't living in LA yet. I was living in Texas, but I had a friend who was working on it and was like, hey, we're gonna do a music video. Do you wanna come? And it's not that far of a drive.
I have friends that I went to college with that lived in New Mexico. So anyway, I drove there and I was in this music video, but I wore my own clothes. Remember when it was fashion for people to wear construction boots? Yeah. Right, but I wore my own clothes. Remember when like it was fashion for people to wear like construction boots? Yeah. Right. But like with shorts. Yeah. I think that's still in fashion. Is it? Is it still in fashion? Is it that? Like the yellow construction boots? I think and I feel like maybe it is. Yeah. And then I wore like a sweater tucked into
shorts. What? But that's where you lost me. Yeah. I don't know if that was ever in. And then I wore like I would have done it. Chunky belt. Anyway, it was a look. And you can barely see me. I'm literally a blur. I'm sitting on like where the little concert was with a group of people and we're like singing along with Clay and the camera pans past us, but it's like a blur. And it was his song,
If I could make a million out of loving you, I'd be a millionaire in a week or two. I love that song. I'd be doing what I love and love and what I do. Now lady. It's a great song. Did you get paid? Is it your first like professional on-camera gig?
If it was pre LA? Is this your Jurassic Park water ride moment? Yes. Was dancing repeatedly to this song? Yes, this is my first entertainment gig. Wow. Clay Walker. There you have it.
If you literally blink, you'll miss me. Yeah. I'm barely in it. Well, before we go, everybody, we did have some fans send in a bullsh** card about this whole episode series. Oh, bullsh** card. Yeah. Let's hear it.
You mentioned it in our intro. Fans said they think it's crazy that Kelly, Ryan, and Aaron were in a band that made two music videos and this fact never made it into an actual episode of the show. Oh yeah. I agree with this bulls**t card. Same. I mean, if Toby's radon runner can make it for years, why couldn't subtle sexuality have a moment in the series? I agree. And listen, finally, in researching this webisode, I found the most amazing fan tribute video. It's phenomenal.
A group of women hired a professional videographer and they recreated the male prima donna music video shot by shot. They even have on the costumes. They have all the dance moves. It is such an achievement. We have to share it. We have to put it in our stories. I was riveted. It's very special. It made me want to do it. It made me want to do this, like with a group of friends, like pick a music video you love and just go for it. Recreate it. Yes. Shot by shot. Yeah.
Ah, all right, well, everyone, there you have it. That's our breakdown of subtle sexuality. And before we go, yesterday was World Cancer Day. And I'd like to mention an initiative that I'm supporting called Screening Time Off. I am so glad you're doing this. Well, I think you guys know my breast cancer was discovered during a routine mammogram and ultrasound.
I had been putting them off because, well, it's annoying, trying to find time for cancer screenings and doctor's appointments. But luckily, I went when I did. My cancer was found early and it was treatable. But if I had waited a few months longer, things could have been way worse. And caught early, many cancers have survival rates
well over 90%. However, most people don't prioritize their recommended screenings. And one of the biggest reasons why is because they can't get time off work. Yeah. So that's why I'm trying to get the word out about the Screening Time Off program, which encourages employees to take time to step out for screenings by asking employers
to join Screening Time Off to take the pledge that you will let your employees off to get these screenings. This seems like such a no-brainer. To let your employees be proactive in their health. Yes, so get your screenings everyone. And if you would like to be the world's best boss, do you see what I did there? I do.
You can learn more and sign up at WorkingWithCancerpledge.com. I'll share all of that in our stories. Well, thank you everyone for listening and a big thank you to Nate Fetterman and Joya Balfour for sending us so much great stuff about this episode. Yes, and thank you to my husband Josh, who last night helped me iron on these decals onto shirts.
And you know, one last thing that Joya shared with us was that there was a Mel Prima Donna remix version. It's super fun and I think we should hear it as we go to credits. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.